will highlight that as a matter of
long-standing policy just because
classified information may be posted
online or elsewhere does not mean it has
been Declassified by a classification
Authority
and those of you who have been covering
the Pentagon for a long time know that
we're just not going to discuss or
confirm classified information due to
the potential impact on National
Security as well as the Safety and
Security of our personnel and those of
our allies and our partners and for that
reason we will continue to encourage
those of you who are reporting the story
to take these latter factors into
account
and to consider the potential
consequences of posting potentially
sensitive documents or information
online or elsewhere
separately secretary Austin hosted
Latvia's minister of defense inaro
mernisse today at the Pentagon the
leaders discussed the strength of the
U.S lot via defense relationship and
ongoing efforts to support Ukraine they
also discussed shared security interests
in Europe including NATO's deterrence
and defense posture ahead of the July
NATO Summit in Vilnius a readout will be
available later today
staying on Europe for a moment next week
secretary Austin will travel to Sweden
to meet with his counterpart to discuss
security related topics shared by our
two Nations
from there he'll travel to Germany where
he and chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff General milley will host an
in-person meeting on April 21 of the
Ukraine defense contact group at
Ramstein Air Base this will be the 11th
meeting of the udcg since this vital
form was established by secretary Austin
one year ago
the secretary and general milley will
join Ministers of defense and Senior
military officials from nearly 50
Nations around the world to discuss the
ongoing crisis in Ukraine and to
continue our close coordination on
providing the Ukrainian people with the
means necessary to protect themselves
against Russia's unprovoked and illegal
aggression and as we've highlighted
before the contact group has been
instrumental in identifying
synchronizing and ensuring delivery of
the military capabilities the ukrainians
need to defend their Homeland
and on a semi-related note at the end of
this month the Arkansas Army National
Guard's 39th infantry Brigade combat
team will replace the New York Army
National Guard's 27th infantry Brigade
combat team and assumed command of the
joint multinational training group
Ukraine at grafenbeer training area in
Germany
the 27th infantry Brigade combat team
took charge of the jmtgu during a
transfer Authority ceremony in August of
2022 becoming the first and only unit in
the jmtgu's eight-year history to assume
the unit mission for a second time we
look forward to the arrival of the 39th
and the continuation of the important
work to provide Ukraine what it needs in
terms of training to defend itself and
with that I'll be happy to go to your
questions we'll go ahead and start with
AP to our cup
uh thank you General Ryder so can you
confirm that everyone Airman First Class
Jack Teixeira a member of the
Massachusetts Air National Guard is a
person of interest in this leaked
documents case I have several other
questions sure so first of all as I
mentioned there is an ongoing criminal
investigation and so anything related to
that I'm going to need to refer you to
the the doj or the FBI can you speak at
all to if anyone in the Department of
Defense has reached out to this Airman
do you know where he is there are
reports that law enforcement is closing
in on this airman's location
um
so has anyone been able to reach out to
him again Tara I appreciate the question
but again given that this is an ongoing
investigation I'm not going to be able
to talk about the investigation or any
potential doj actions so I'd refer you
to them okay in the days after the leaks
came to light what steps has DOD taken
to reduce the number of people who have
access to not only these classified
briefings but the classified material in
general sure so we continue to review a
variety of factors as it relates to
safeguarding classified materials this
includes examining and updating
distribution lists assessing how and
where intelligence products are shared
in a variety of other steps I would say
though that is it is important to
understand
that we do have stringent guidelines in
place for safeguarding classified and
sensitive information this was a
deliberate criminal act a violation of
those guidelines uh and so again I think
that's important to understand now we
will continue to do everything we can to
ensure that that people who have a need
to know uh when it comes to this kind of
information have access to that
um we're always going to learn from
every situation
um but again
um this is something that we'll continue
to look at but you are taking steps to
tighten that I guess population who
might have access to this level of
information that's accurate again we
continue to review those distribution
lists update them make sure there's a
need to know but again let me just
emphasize my point that this was a you
know we have rules in place each of us
signs a non-disclosure agreement anybody
that has a uh has a security clearance
and so all indications are again this is
a criminal act a willful violation of
those uh and and again another reason
why we're continuing to investigate and
support doj's investigation just last
question
um do you have a sense that this is just
the act of one individual and even if so
wouldn't members of his chain of command
also be held accountable for this lost
information again I don't want to
speculate or get ahead of the doj's
investigation we need to allow that to
run its course and so I'd refer you to
them let me go ahead and go to Board and
they'll come back to June
yeah but there's two questions one just
uh to clarify in in dod's efforts to
change the way you do business in terms
of protecting classified information
apart from the stuff that you do already
is that DOD LED or is that joint staff
LED who's kind of directing what on that
and the second question is just
hypothetically I know you like
hypotheticals if somebody was to be
charged what would determine whether the
military would charge and indict and
you know carry out the legal process
against that person or people or doj
yeah so on your latter question you're
right I don't want to get into
hypotheticals I will say that you know
as always every case is judged on its
own Merit and we need to allow this
investigation to run its course and then
of course there'll be more to say on
that
um on your first question uh again it's
it's important to understand that this
is uh not just about DOD this is about
the US government this is about how we
protect and Safeguard classified
information and as I highlighted we do
have strict protocols in place so
anytime there is an incident anytime
There's an opportunity to review that
and refine it we're of course going to
take advantage of that within the
Department of Defense
as you've heard us say secretary Austin
has been convening daily meetings with
his senior leaders to include the
chairman to talk about
reviewing the scope and the impact of
this and also to look at mitigation
measures and what we need to do across
the Department of Defense to ensure that
we're doing our utmost to reinforce
existing policies procedures and rules
and if there are any areas where we need
to tighten things up we certainly will
that's correct as I mentioned
uh when I say DOD I mean the Department
of Defense across the entire Enterprise
okay Jen
General writer you say that there are
strict protocols in place and yet a 21
year old Airman was able to access some
of the nation's top secrets how did this
happen and isn't this a massive security
breach
again we need to allow the investigation
to run its course we'll of course know
more when that is completed so I'd refer
you to to doj on that what is your
message to anyone who might be thinking
leaking these kind of documents in the
future look again we have procedures we
have protocols in place we receive
regular training on the proper handling
of classified information as I mentioned
we saw a non-disclosure agreements so
those rules are very clear and anyone
who has a security clearance knows that
anyone who violates those rules is doing
so willfully
context the damage that has been done by
this leak again right now we're
continuing to assess the scope and the
impact and so that's work that will be
ongoing
Tony
how large was the distribution Network
for these documents say prior to last
Thursday when the disclosures came out
are we talking in thousands of people
that access inside the Pentagon and
outside the Pentagon to include Europe
and bases around the United States yeah
Tony so I don't I don't have any numbers
to provide you as as I'm sure you can
appreciate the Department of Defense and
all of our components it's a global
Enterprise doing work in all areas of
the world and so certainly we have
people who have access to information
that they need to do their jobs but I
don't have any numbers for you can you
say it was widespread though versus you
know outside the Pentagon though and to
other military installations well again
the Department of Defense we conduct
Global operations so intelligence
products operational information
products are shared with DOD leaders and
Personnel globally throughout the world
whether it's at a component command
whether it's in the services but again
the important thing to understand about
classified information it's not a just I
want to have access to it because I have
a clearance it's all based on need to
know do you have a need to know that
information and that typically will
grant you access if you have the
appropriate clearances thank you Travis
thanks Pat
um I'm still confused on the access
issue you said that there were changes
that were made but you also said that
you're reviewing things can you tell us
where are there less people who have
access to this type of information today
than there were a week ago
uh so Travis again I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna get down to numbers again
reviewing distribution lists looking at
who has a need to know making sure those
things are updated doing due diligence
in the wake of these unauthorized
disclosures again though I want to
emphasize that this was a deliberate
criminal act to violate those guidelines
and rules in the same way that if you
locked your front door and somebody came
into your house and took something you
you followed your procedures and you
locked your door but somebody went in
your house and took something and put it
out on the street that's what we're
talking about here let me go to Carla
questions on this and then I have a
follow on something separate why did it
take so long to brief the secretary
about the leaks he said that he was
briefed on April the 6th and would you
classify that delay as a failure of the
open source intelligence teams
absolutely not we were notified you know
the department became aware on the fifth
the secretary was briefed hours later in
the morning of the six I don't consider
that the delay thanks to follow on that
these documents were available long
before April 5th and 6th so what took so
long for DOD in the intelligence
communities to to locate these documents
yeah so that's really something that the
investigation will tell us that said I
think it's important remember that that
dod's intelligence activities are
primarily focused internationally so to
the extent that the department collects
any information related to U.S persons
for example or gaming chat rooms it
would have to be conducted in accordance
with law and policy and in a manner that
protects private C and civil liberties
so again we'll know more at the
culmination of this investigation thank
you
just the Syria really quickly on the
Syria attacks from March do we have a
final conclusion on the TBI assessments
how many U.S troops received tvis as a
result of these attacks and do you
believe that the U.S strikes have that
that happened on 323 the retaliatory
strikes do you believe that they've
deterred Iranian back groups from
targeting U.S forces yeah yes so on the
on the TBI my understanding is centcom
has collected some additional
information so we'll get that to you and
and the the Press uh Team here
um in terms of deterrence again we're
going to continue to do everything that
we need to do at a time and place of our
choosing to ensure that we're deterring
and safeguarding our folks
um just leave it at that thank you let
me go to Dave
can you just tell us what the mission of
the 101st 102nd intelligence wing for
the Massachusetts Air National Guard was
and are you going to release this
airman's service record
in response to I'm sure the thousands of
requests you've already gotten yeah so
so David on the the service record again
we'll we'll take that and we'll provide
an update when we're able to in terms of
the 102nd intelligence Wing I don't have
that in front of me I'm positive they
have a website we can quickly find the
fact sheet up there in general
intelligence Wings throughout the Air
Force support is what you might imagine
Air Force intelligence requirements
worldwide uh to support a variety of
types of intelligence missions and
requirements so which include active
guard and Reserve components so let me
go Brandi I'm gonna come to Warren thank
you so much General Ryder what
technologies is the Pentagon applying
right now to both spot leaked documents
online and track potential indicators of
leaking type practices do you plan to be
investing in more
um again Brandy so when it comes to this
particular situation we'll know more
when the investigation is concluded
as I highlighted when it comes to
intelligence collection within the
Department of Defense that's focused
primarily internationally I'm not going
to get into the specifics of where how
and when we conduct our intelligence
activities but we're always looking at
potential gaps potential vulnerabilities
and that's something that will just be
ongoing work you are using Technologies
right now to spot potential leakers of
future documents
um it's you're asking me a hypothetical
basically again we're we're always going
to be on the lookout we're always going
to be on the lookout for any potential
Insider threats again we get training
um on how to spot Insider threats but
again as I mentioned to Travis you've
locked your door you've lent some keys
to your friends if one of those friends
decides to give the keys away you know
hopefully you've been able to clue in on
those signals so we'll continue it gets
lost onto anyone in this room that this
is all happening at the same time that
deputy secretary Hicks is conducting a
review of the pentagon's classification
practices and at times over
classification so can you talk about how
this incident is informing that ongoing
review
um again I think that there's the
investigation that the doj is conducting
and then you're talking about something
separately which is again our review of
classification requirements
acknowledging that where we need to be
better in terms of of classification so
having no impact on
I want to come back to the question of
distribution from on two different
questions given the gravity of the
situation are you actively paring down
the distribution list now is this a
process that's moving quickly or is it
going to take time for there to be
meaningful substantive changes to the
distribution and then is DoD or has DOD
taking additional measures to restrict
the access to classified information of
others in the Massachusetts Air National
Guard uh so Oren broadly speaking I
think I've already answered the question
that yes we are taking and have taken
steps to review distribution lists and
to ensure that that folks receiving
information have a need to know but
again
to belabor the point we have safeguards
in place we have processes we have
procedures we'll continue to do due
diligence as part of this review to
ensure that we're doing everything we
can to prevent potential unauthorized
disclosures in the future recognizing
that again this was a criminal
deliberate act thank you
again I don't have anything on that
row
thank you very much General also please
let me ask you a question about China
two questions about China well free free
read the room yeah
yeah
um uh the China conducted a three-day
exercises around Taiwan and still
continue the combat training around
Taiwan so do you assess China has
overreacted to the meeting between
President Tsai and speaker McCarthy
yes thanks Rose so um
we obviously uh continue to monitor the
situation in the Taiwan Strait very
closely as well as the the prc's
military exercise
you've heard other uh others say that
from a U.S government perspective these
military exercises undermine peace and
stability across the Taiwan Strait which
is critical to Global Prosperity you
know they estimate
upwards of a few trillion dollars of
global Commerce going through that that
straight regularly uh and and so as
we've said there is no reason for
Beijing to turn uh president-sized
Transit which was consistent with
long-standing U.S policy into something
that it's not or use it as a pretext to
overreact and so we'll continue to do
everything we can to maintain open
channels of communication with the PRC
um and uh
we will not be deterred the U.S U.S will
not be deterred from operating safely
and responsibly in the seas and the
skies in the Western Pacific consistent
with international law just one quick
follow-up uh the Chinese military
exercises accumulated the blockade of
Taiwan are you confident that the U.S
military is capable of breaking Chinese
brocade around Taiwan well again I'm not
going to get into hypotheticals and I'm
not going to talk about uh you know or
speculate on on future scenarios again
we're going to work closely with our
allies and our partners in the region to
focus on our primary goal which is peace
stability and Security in the region and
so that will continue to be our primary
focus okay let me go back over here Will
and Laura
thank you um what is the scope of the
leak as identified by by DOD so far are
we talking tens hundreds thousands of
documents and then second the US has
been reviewing the authenticity of the
documents for for several days now what
has been found so far on that
yeah thanks so uh so that work is
ongoing will I'm not going to be able to
provide you with a overall number of
documents uh we're just going to
continue to to look at this uh as you
highlight you know some of the initial
indications were that some of those
documents had been altered
um again for obvious reasons I'm not
going to go into which ones were or
weren't
um but that is work that we continue to
do take a look at Laura
thank you sort of as a follow-on to
Carla and Brandy's questions
um can you say whether DOD has anyone
looking at chat rooms on Discord for
example or other social media platforms
right now for leaked information and um
if not should should DOD have these
people so so doj uh is as I understand
it uh has is working with Discord or
Discord has come out publicly to say
they are cooperating with the doj so
that's really a question for for doj to
tell you is that is that a no that DOD I
think I already answered the question in
terms of what our focus is on it's
primarily focused on uh International uh
I'm not going to get into the specifics
of what intelligence
activities we're conducting or not other
than to say when we do conduct those
activities they're in compliance with
the law and with policy okay you've got
a gym and they'll come back over here
thanks general you know every time
something like this happens there's a
huge tendency to clamp down on
everything but that sort of ends up
throwing the baby out with the bath
water if you know what I mean is there
any sort of idea in the department that
the Intel does need to be shared it just
needs to go to the correct people is
there a study going on with that yeah so
uh thanks Jim so as I mentioned uh there
has been daily meetings with the
secretary and the senior DOD leadership
team we're taking this very seriously to
look again that the scope the impact and
importantly the mitigation measures I
will tell you uh that these discussions
are very focused very deliberate and
very measured and sure in terms of
ensuring that we're doing the right
things while not impeding or impacting
our ability to do our important missions
worldwide and so uh you know just uh to
put it frankly we're continuing to
conduct our operations and provide
people with the information they need
without missing a beat thanks all right
let me come over here I'll go here and
then here yeah thanks Pat Deborah would
a junior service member like an Airman
in the Massachusetts guard or any other
Junior service member typically have the
level of security clearances that would
allow them access to such uh sensitive
information like joint staff briefing
documents yeah so again let me just
preface what I'm about to tell you with
I'm not going to talk about a particular
individual I'm not going to talk about
the investigation I'm not going to again
have to refer you to doj for that let's
take a step back for a second let's talk
about security clearances when you join
the military depending on your position
you may require a security clearance and
if you are working in the intelligence
community and you require a security
clearance you're going to go through the
proper vetting
we entrust our members with a lot of
responsibility at a very early age think
about a young combat
you know platoon Sergeant uh and the and
the responsibility and trust that we put
into those individuals to lead troops
into combat uh that that's just one
example across the board so you've
received training uh and you will
receive an understanding of the rules
and requirements that come along with
those responsibilities and you're
expected to abide by those rules
regulations and responsibility it's
called military discipline and in
certain cases especially when it comes
to sensitive information it also is
about the law so I'll just leave it at
that customer
thank you very much so a separate topic
last week sandcom confirmed that three
U.S service members were with the ypg
SDF ring leader Muslim Abdi when he was
apparently targeted in an airstrike in
so Northern Iraq suleimania my question
is what was the mission or engagements
that the U.S service members involved
alongside Muslim Abdi in suleimania and
also where this engagements authorized
or permitted by the Iraqi central
government or not yeah so let me let me
tell you what I've got on this custom so
uh on April 7 Convoy including U.S
Personnel was fired upon while in
transit within the Iraqi Kurdistan
region in the area near suleimania
um U.S forces in are in Iraq and Syria
as you know in support of local partner
forces uh in support of the defeat Isis
Mission the enduring defeat of Isis and
so
um in this particular incident we can
confirm that there were no casualties uh
that the strike uh was not a near-miss
it struck more than 100 meters from the
Convoy and centcom is currently
investigating the incident so I'd refer
you to syncom is there what was the
mission of the U.S tourist members and
was it was it somehow allowed they're
they're conducting uh the in support of
the defeat Isis Mission the Iraqi
government was it authorized by RCA
government because Muslim well we're
supporting the Iraqi uh Security Forces
as part of the defeat Isis Mission as
you know we have we have forces in Iraq
they're not conducting combat operations
they're there advising and assisting the
Iraqis and then we have forces in Syria
that are supporting the SDF so again
there's a uh you know an intra theater
Mission in terms of the defeat Isis
missions
in Syria you are cooperating with him
well these the oi and I need to move on
but the oir headquarters is in Iraq
right uh but they conduct operations in
support of defeat Isis mission in Syria
and Iraq so let me go ahead yes sir
if I may I'd like to remain on the same
subject actually I've got one question
about this I pose the same question to
the state department on Monday and I was
referred to the Department of Defense so
that's why
um the question is when the U.S
servicemen U.S military members are
riding with the head of the SDF doesn't
that isn't there a concern within the
Department of Defense that those U.S
servicemen are also made a legitimate
Target not least one of your greatest
NATO allies because of his decades-long
relationship with the pkk that I think
I'm sure is very much known to the U.S
intelligence community so so no
SDF we've partnered with the SDF since
uh you know 2015 2014 as as part of the
defeat Isis Mission we have a
long-standing relationship with them
they're not the pkk we are partnered
with SDF to defeat Isis so no we we've
been conducting partnered operations for
a very long time so let me let me go
ahead and move on yep sir
yeah we'll go to you and then to Megan
thanks Pat just two two quick follow-ups
to questions one was from Roe in regards
to the Chinese activities around Taiwan
before they did the military exercises
they were conducting an exercise to
which uh depending on described as well
they were in international waters it's
simply what we do in international
waters at what point does it move from
being international waters to an
overreaction that's my first question
please and my second one in regards to
what you said earlier in this briefing
uh even though it's the investigations
going on and such but you're confident
that by you said several times that this
is a violation of Law and as we all
signed non-disclosure agreements not me
but we at the Pentagon so you're
confident that those two factors will
remain when the investigation concludes
yeah so on your latter questions again
I'm not going to discuss the ongoing
investigation by virtue of the fact that
photographed documents uh of sensitive
information Nation are posted by default
is a violation of of uh you know how to
properly handle and Safeguard sensitive
information so it is a criminal act and
then in terms of your your first
question
um I would just have to take a little
bit of an exception of conducting
simulated uh strikes against Taiwan is
not just that that's not just operating
peacefully in international waters and
so again yes we would call that an
overreaction yep okay let me go back to
let me get a few more here let me go
back to Kelly and then over here to Jill
thank you you mentioned taking steps to
review the distribution lists and ensure
that folks receiving information have a
need to know but this isn't the first
time you've had that kind of Crackdown
on this to limit uh who's on these
distribution lists so my question is how
did this happen how wasn't this solved
before and how did potentially a 21 year
old have a need to know again we need to
allow the investigation time to run its
course
um and so again I'd
defer you to the Department of Justice
when it comes to suspects uh you know on
that
um and again look this is uh something
that we that will continue to be
important work to ensure that
um
there's you know an understanding of the
the rules and regulations again we have
strict safeguards in place
and people are expected to abide by
those just leave it at that over here
thanks General a quick one on the Syria
uh strike so just to clarify there has
been no attribution to who was behind
that attack with the three again my
understanding is it's continued uh
centcom is investigating so I'd I'd
refer you to that second the yesterday
uh Reuters cited several sources
including Intel officials as saying that
they've seen uh Iranian weapons being
moved into Syria
following these following certain uh
sanctions waivers falling the earthquake
has DOD seen any Iran any increase or
uptick in Iranian weapons heading for
Syria yeah things I don't I don't have
anything to provide from here other than
again we you know as evidenced by the uh
irgc aligned groups in Syria we know
that Iran conducts malign activities
within Syria so I got time for two more
Megan and then and then we'll end on tar
um several media reports have said that
the Airmen in question was working at
Fort Bragg at the time that the
documents were put online was he on
title 10 orders at the time or has he
been on title 10 orders since yeah
thanks Megan again I don't have anything
to provide on that front after a refer
you to doj and when we have more uh to
provide we certainly will follow up um
has the leak prompted any discussion at
OSD about either tightening policies or
bulking up training for opsec or social
media again our review is ongoing I've
mentioned some of the steps that we've
taken and we're going to do everything
that we need to do to do due diligence
to ensure that we are properly
safeguarding classified information
again I can't emphasize enough that this
is something that secretary Austin and
the entire department are taking very
very seriously we understand
the impact that an unauthorized
disclosure like this can have on
National Security and so again it's
something that will continue to work
very hard on thank you we'll go here and
then over at Target
thank you General this morning the prime
minister of Poland gave remarks
that were very supportive of Ukraine's
ambition stated ambition to join both
the EU and NATO NATO alliance from a
strictly military perspective would you
see any benefit
um
to Ukraine joining these these two
organizations and especially for the
wider defensive posture there in in the
area yeah thanks
um so that's not really something for me
to comment on obviously I refer you to
to Ukraine to talk about its
perspectives on joining nato in the EU
just leave it at that tar
the Associated Press has confirmed that
federal agents have taken in
Massachusetts Air National Guardsmen
into custody at this point could you
speak a little bit more about this case
I cannot I again refer you to doj it's
an ongoing doj investigation and
activity so I'd refer you to them and
again I I will say when we do have more
to provide we certainly will
okay thank you very much everybody
appreciate it